and again it will be about the opening
and it will be about a specific
variation called the pin variation how
many of you play E for me for how many
of you play Sicilian we played the
Sicilian or like the Sicilian what have
you well one of the things that happens
in chess of course is that the game of
chess itself is a battle of ideas
that's what chess is all about it's a
battle of ideas and with the move e for
so with his opening move e to e for
Bobby Fischer's comment was best by test
and we certainly understand this move
obviously it controls the c-suite Center
d5 controls it prepares to develop the
Bishop the Queen it's simply the oldest
move in chess fine well I like to play
the Sicilian so I would play the move
c7 c5 my opponents who played efore
invariably chose what we call the open
Sicilian they would play the move Knight
f3 this is a million games in the
database has been played like this I
like the movie 7e 6 and again we have
the open Sicilian that move the the open
Sicilian is to provide by the move D to
d4 I capture the pawn my opponent
recaptures so again in this battle of
ideas what was going on in my head is I
want to refute White's position well
that's quite a statement to make I want
I want to prove
that this position is good for black
well how can I even try to make such a
statement okay well it basically has to
do with what we call material what do I
mean by that if we look at the material
the materials even so why do I think
that blacks ahead okay I did say this
was for the advanced class okay when we
start the game of chess we're all told
that the pawns are all worth one yeah
pawns are all worth one that the Knights
are worth three the bishops are worth
three the rooks are worth five the
Queen's worth nine and so on
a lot a lot of tables don't tell you is
that the King actually has a value you
can't lose the King of course we
understand but it has a point value of
three and a half three and a Hannah so
in other words if it was a King versus
night the King could boss the night
around you think about that in terms of
an ending but if I take this pawn on a
two and I compare it to this pawn on b2
well it doesn't really compare that pawn
on b2 has more options than pawn on a
two in other words that pawn on a two
could only capture on the B 3 square
currently the pawn on B 2 can capture on
the a3 as well as the C 3 square doesn't
it therefore stand to reason that
however marginal may be just very very
small in fact that pawn on B to actually
stand superior to the pond honey - yes
in lady
precisely
that's exactly what I'm getting it we
could say that this pond on c2 is
marginally better than the pawn on b2
for the simple reason that think about
our central square the pawn on c4 could
go the pawn on C to go to c4 and could
control the sweet center so it stands to
reason that this pawn isn't worth one
this pond might be worth nine tenths of
one or eight tenths of one this pond is
certainly worth one this pond might be
worth a little bit more than one and
finally the two ponds on Eve on the
e-file in the D file might be worth one
point ten or one point twenty so from a
material point of view I was traded the
pawn on c7 for the pawn on d2 and I've
gained I have more control of the center
but now I want to prove it now I want to
prove it so my next move was Knight f6
attacking the pawn on e4 and I can't
tell you how delighted I was when some
of my beginner friends would play the
move e5 against me and I would quickly
come out here with a check and snap that
pot that was like oh that was a favorite
tactic and you'd be surprised how many
players actually have this moment of
blindness and they overlook this move
now after Knight f6 it's been
established through many many many
decades of master practice there's one
and only one good move in the position
for white white has tried the move
Bishop d3 but every chess book will say
that after Bishop d3 knight c6 Knight
takes c6 be take C
six castles d5 black stands fine like
stands well well I will even go so far
as to say well I like blacks position in
this position I have one two three four
units in play you have one two three
four units as soon as I can so I'll
catch up in development and surpass you
and in the meantime my control of the
center with pawns is actually better
than whites so this has been established
in many many many decades of practice
and the move Knight c3
is absolutely required this is not only
White's best move it's his only move to
pretend to have an advantage okay
Knight c3 now I I did what I call and I
think everybody else calls I'm not 100%
sure the pin variation Bishop b4 this is
as crude as it looks the knight on c3
protects the pawn on e4 by pinning the
knight on c3 I'm just ready to play the
move Knight takes e4 and I basically
challenge white to do something about it
well I'm not the only person who likes
the pen variation and the pin variation
came many many many years I happy to say
before I was born so everybody says that
after the move Bishop d3 and they almost
put a question mark on that move knight
c6 Knight takes c6 b takes c6 in this
position they actually think that black
is better than he was a move ago because
the moves Bishop b4 and Knight to c3 are
considered advantageous for black so
everybody says there's one and one move
only for white
that's the move e4 e5 any questions so
far the the play has been quite logical
correct correct okay so we're going to
pause here for a moment and I'll talk
conceptually for just a moment about the
Sicilian one of the interesting things
about the Sicilian from the point of
view of the black player is that with
the elimination of the pawn on c7 he has
what we call the half-open C file in
other words this rook on a ate
oftentimes comes to the C file because
from blacks point of view the C file is
open from White's point of view the D
pawn is missing so that white has the
half open D file and oftentimes you see
in open Sicilians that white will put
his queen on D 2 and will Castle long
and he'll double or create a battery on
the D file from blacks point of view
when he brings his rook from a 8 to c8
its attacking this knight on c3 and
countless number of games black has
sacrificed an exchange on c3 not always
winning of course but that's been a very
very common tactic one of the reasons
that he does that is because he really
breaks up white queenside structure
creating a double pawn here on c2 and c3
as well as an isolated pawn on a2 that's
important because as we progress that's
exactly the structure I'm trying to
achieve as black without losing an
exchange yeah
just a second where am I okay so II five
I play Knight to d5 attacking the knight
on c3 so far everything seems very very
logical and very forceful but suddenly
white white is facing a crossroads white
notices that the move Knight takes c3 B
takes c3 Bishop takes c3 check is a
devastating threat it's a devastating
threat so he has to do something about
it
suggestions for white if you place any
suggestions you might have in the first
place should white try to guard against
the threat should he play for example a
move like Bishop d2 or should he play
for example a move like Knight b5 these
do guard against the threat that maybe
would not lead to an advantage for white
well it turns out that in one place the
move Knight b5 shouldn't be considered
very good because after a 7 a 6 a 3
takes tanks rook takes oops that's an
accident that cost wider rook and after
a six-night d6 check Bishop takes d6
pawn takes c6 Knight takes c3
B takes c3 White has not successfully
prevented black from doubling his C 3
and C two pawns
perhaps in this position for example
black could play a move like Queen b3
with ideas of capturing oops capturing
this pawn on c3 and a white force for
example to defend the pawn black consid
consider a move like b5 where after the
moves Bishop b7 knight c6 is pretty
clear that black is getting harmonious
development and White's pawn structure
is not particularly attractive let's go
back back back and we'll look at this
position let's suggest another move
Bishop d2 this indeed does defend
against blacks threat but after Knight
takes c3 B takes c3 Bishop e7 well white
has shattered pawns and he better show
something for it so we're going to go
back also there's a consideration from
blacks point of view that might white
might have feared Bishop takes c3 B
takes c3 Queen c7 attacking this pawn on
'if I've as well as this pawn on c3 in
any case the verdict is clear 95 Bishop
d2 are both bad moves for white and
should not be played again after many
many countless master games it is
considered that the only move for white
the only move for white is the move
Queen g4 so let's try to understand this
battle I of ideas the logic behind the
move Queen g4 and we if we think about
it it kind of makes sense it's move
Queen g4 we might try to humble black
and say your move Bishop b4 was ultra
aggressive and because you've left the
station early so to speak you've left
the pawn on g7 unprotected therefore I'm
going to has white attack your pawn okay
so let's try to understand what's going
on here the first point is the Queen on
g4 tax the pawn on g7 if black result
Lee tries to continue with his threat
which he imagine is very powerful Knight
takes c3 White has Queen takes g7
attacking the rook in the corner if the
knight moves for example Knight d5 with
a discover check well then after c3
black discovers that two of his pieces
are hanging the bishop on b4 as well as
the rook on h8 and black isn't happy so
instead black plays the move rook
rook f8 hoping that light will capture
his knight and then black would win
brilliantly after Bishop takes c3 check
well white has is very annoying little
move a2 a3 and after the move Bishop
drops back then black has another very
nasty little move and I believe it's
Bishop h6 oh maybe it's even Bishop g5
again in all of these cases master games
have shown that this position is very
unfavorable for black so we're going to
go back back back to the move Queen g4
so we tip our hats we say to white
congratulations you've developed your
queen with a gain of tempo I am going to
play the move g7 g6 many masters have
tried a different line in this they've
tried castles which I don't like they've
tried castles Bishop h6 g6 Bishop takes
Queen takes sacrificing an exchange
remember what I was saying to you about
rook c8 take c3
well black sacrifices in exchange a
different way this one this time the
rook on f8 but I don't like this
variation for black I prefer the move g7
to g6 and again I'm I'm saying to white
please defend my threat of Knight takes
c3 and again numerous games have been
played numerous games Knight b5 has been
tried Bishop d2 has been tried and in
each and
BK's those moves have been found wanting
the one and only move that be
encyclopedias of chess openings show is
any good for white is this move queen g3
well queen g3 actually has two nice
points to it the first and the moment
ago I think I pointed out to you that
Queen c7 was a potential threat against
c3 and e5 with the move Queen g3 both
weak points are protected so far so good
everybody says Queen g3 is the best move
and now black reinforces his threat with
Queen a5 he's really bearing down
against this c3 Knight I like that
expression I don't know I think it was
[ __ ] a covert artico versus said
everything Penniman Wynnum i want to
make this night the focus of my
attention okay essentially Queen a5 has
been played before the move Bishop d2 is
considered the one and only move for
white knight takes c3 b takes c3 Bishop
e7 ok so remember what I started out
with with the lecture chess is a battle
of ideas and in this opening my idea for
black has been up as nothing short of
resolute I want to refute White's
position essentially what I've done is
I've made a material plus by trading
this one for this see perceived pawn for
the D pawn far more importantly I've
completely completely shattered White's
Queen side to put that in perspective
how many opening sicilians games have
you seen where
White has Castle queenside well that
that option for white has simply been
torn away there is no way you're
castling queenside is white in this
position just not going to happen
from whites point of view well what are
the scales from whites point of view one
two three four units and play one two
three four five white has a marginal
Margo just a smidgen a smidgen of better
development for white okay let's
continue the thought process we know
with a near certitude that White's King
is not going Queen side it's possible
with the move Bishop d3 followed by
castling queenside then white will go
the other way very happily thank you
very much so let's just if you have any
questions or suggestions for white like
what do you think white should do should
we make a logical move of Bishop d3 for
just a brief moment Bishop d3 it is I
can hear you're all cheering Bishop d3
very logical bringing another piece into
play I play the nut move knight c6 also
quite logical with the move knight c6
I basically say to white oh by the way
please
do notice that my queen on a5 attacks
your pawn on CC on e5 after Bishop d3
knight c6 white is practically speaking
obliged to trade I recapture
now white completes if you will his
development now a moment ago I showed
you a position where after my castling
after I canceled you played Bishop h6
and won an exchange well here I have two
very easy avenues I can Castle or Castle
kingside I beg your pardon
or I can Castle queenside for example I
could play a move such as Bishop d7 and
go over here I could play a move such as
b7 b6 new variation with the idea of
putting my Bishop on b7 in castling or I
could just simply castle on the Kings
side when I Castle on the King side we
can visualize that White's two bishops
are radiating energy down the c1
diagonal as well as a c2 diagonal these
bishops are aimed at our King and we can
imagine that white will soon play h4 h5
to soften up our King sight so we don't
like castles we like the ship d7 instead
takes takes castles Bishop d7 and now we
have a position where at the moment
White has an advantage in space but he
has to overcome his shattered Queen
sight my experience has told me that
blacks game is not only playable it's
really good and in truth the move Bishop
d3 is not the move given by the theory
as White's best White's best move
according to the chests theoretician
is the move h4 and so what's the logic
behind that play well the logic here is
that white agrees with black that he's
not moving his came to the Kings side
but white believes that after he plays
the move
h5 his rook he could open up the King
side to his advantage
how many of you like to move h4 not so
much beside the move h4 or the move
Bishop d3 is there a suggestion for
white other than those two moves those
two moves look like the most logical
moves in the position right well we saw
the results of Bishop d3 let's look at
the results of h4 so this is like my my
secret analysis this is like what I
would I would like to do and in fact I
showed it to my wife Yvette and she used
it to good effect in her Dutch ladies
championships
so h4 very very logical move by white
yvette has played knight c6 so again I
say gift meet the pawn
I want to capture the pawn on e5 White
has captured on c6 recapture and along
comes the move h5 having said a white
says B so the move H takes g6 is a very
very big threat and black steps out of
the way with the move rook f8
so far so good all very logical yes sir
at this moment six
masses
not not the move Knight captures c6 but
rather for example a move like night
here or maybe Knight d5 yeah though the
Queen is blocked
exactly okay so let's go back for a
moment so Bishop h4 I think knight c6
let's see Knight b5 so very very
reasonable idea and one I certainly
certainly took into account
so after Knight b5 what I do with black
is I play the move a seven a six I
attack blacks what for me I attack
White's knight and say please kind sir
hit move again let us just say for in
the first case that white decides that
it's in his best interest to jump to d6
I would capture capture and now I would
play the move Queen e5 and I'd offer the
trade of Queens in case white decided to
swap Queens we end up in an endgame
which is a kind of a it's a bit of a
muddy endgame it's very hard to
understand in the first place it looks
like black is playing a kind of checkers
look at all those ponds and but it's
virtually unstoppable that the pawn will
either advance here or to b6 and once
this Bishop gets on this very nice
diagonal a lot of the let us say
weaknesses and blacks apparent position
will disappear will simply disappear but
that is to say that whites and game
prospects will not be good on the
contrary if black could ever play d5
should be seven rook c8 oh boy the sky's
the limit he may just simply take over
the game
one alternative for white is that after
the move a seven a six attacking the
knight if white doesn't go in to d6 with
his knight he could consider the move c4
c3 c4 would be idea of pushing this
Queen the bishop gains a tempo pushing
this Queen to a less favourable square
if the Queen wanders too far for example
there is the move Knight c7 check this
move has a drawback
unfortunately for white otherwise this
position might be very very favorable
for the first player the drawback of
this idea is night b4 so in the first
place black blocks the threat to his
queen in the second place he opens up
his own insidious fork with Knight
captures c2 check again just two can
just to continue to play for a move or
two further in case of ninety six takes
takes Knight takes check King d1 at
first blush you might say
I don't know something weirds happening
I just don't know what what it is
well the queen is being attacked the
knight is being attacked the rook is
being attacked and with the move Queen a
for black gains the upper hand
he not only rescues his Knight and Queen
that he actually has a threat of
capturing a rook with check so might be
five very very worthy alternative but
concrete analysis suggest that black
stands quite okay after such a line
let's go back and we continue with oops
that yes yes take stakes h5 so far all
very logical flowing play we understand
logical flowing play like it now in view
of this harsh threat of H takes g6 which
would bring this rook very powerfully on
the open file we step aside we step
aside and we play the move hg hg and
look what white does he invades our camp
rook h7 everything we've done is really
logical flow how many of you like whites
position doesn't it look good he's got
his rook down and be well how many of
you like blacks position think black
solid how many think it's about even
even even hard to say huh okay let's
continue after the move rook h7 we
played Bishop decent developing our
pieces white plays the move Bishop d3 I
Castle
so again white is playing with some
structural flaws his queenside structure
is broken but juni spot the win of a
pond for white in the position can white
win upon after castles yeah yeah yeah
this ship takes g6
how many of you like pawns to win that
pond bishop takes g6 and this is where i
started the lecture that you know what
chess is a battle of ideas and how i
want to refute the open Sicilian for
white they want to show how black has an
advantage check this out after you've
played the move Bishop takes g6 which is
this wonderful long long flowing logic I
take you take and I play the move rook
each egg and I ask a simple question who
is attacking who okay in this position
first of all we have a bishops of
opposite colors position for those of
you familiar with the concept of bishops
of opposite color end games you'll know
that such end games have a great
propensity to being a draw however am
bishops of opposite color middle games
the player who is on the attack has a
huge advantage why because ambitious of
opposite colors the attacker has no
counterpart the defending side can't
block in this position I'd like to say
that black has the LightSquared bishop
white the dark-squared bishop and if you
look at that little bishop on d7 it
really isn't bothering anybody I mean in
fact it's a pretty dormant piece in in
Seattle vernacular
we would call it as a septic bishop a
septic vision but if we could imagine
the move c5 followed by Bishop c6 this
is a little mouse that roared and that
Bishop would be absolutely tremendous
okay in the first place it's white to
move and white has to do something if
it's black to move black is threatening
rook check and rook takes rook and
that's all she wrote
so what could white play King eetu which
is exactly the move I wanted to elicit
kinney to set a light square or dark
square a light square so you're stepping
right in to my upper punch so after your
move King II - I play the move c5 sure I
almost at any moment you could sacrifice
the exchange and maybe it's even a good
idea but it's not like this Bishop on d2
is providing much solace this Bishop on
d2 is also a little bit passive if we
put that Bishop on d6 hey it's a new
ballgame I mean that Bishop could be
well worth in exchange at the moment the
bishop looks to be simply vulnerable to
attack g6 absolutely ideas like Queen
takes so now we go on the attack we go
Queen a6 check the King can't move to
the first rank oops
hey that arrow drew how did that happen
the King would have to move up stairs to
e3 now here the move that I personally
find the most attractive would be
something like
rook d8 attacking this bishop on D -
probably forcing the bishop to step
backwards and here I kind of looking at
the position and I like whites attacking
prospects I'm a bit of a pawn grubber so
I might find a move like Queen C for
attractive I might find a move like
Queen c6 also attractive probably Queen
C for that one seems to do the most for
me in short I like blacks attacking
prospects and it's sort of like white
has been thrown on the defensive he
could like a try his best to bail out
into an ending for example y could try
to go into an ending like this oops
but unfortunately for him there's a
problem with the bishop the bishop on e
one is trapped so white Mike I don't
know push upon push this pawn for
example new mainline and I'll go down
here forcing a swap of rooks by the way
very important and I think this bishop
better move I don't think you want to
lose that on Bishop d2 and something
like B 7 B 6 here and again I just like
the attacking prospects for black so
this is a kind of a strange conundrum we
went through a very sophisticated line
of play with the rational rationale for
each and every move explained and at the
end of the line you know you don't get a
pony you got poop
what happened I mean white played all of
the recommended moves according to the
encyclopedia of chess openings and he
ended up in a poor position so just goes
to show chess is a real battle of ideas
I put this if you can remember the line
put it through your computer and I think
you'll be amazed white keeps something
like half upon it advantage to maybe an
eighth of upon advantage and all the
moves that we have played in the
computer I changed my mind I really
really really like blacks position so
it's like wow what a what a massive
switch that the computer makes